ينضم المئات الى جنازتي فلسطينيين قتل في
هجوم للجيش الاسرائيلي على مخيم جنين
شمالي الضفه الغربيه المحتله
اندلعت مواجهه بين المواطنين الفلسطينيين
والقوات الاسرائيليه بعد فتره وجيزه من
اقتحامها للمخيم حيث اعتقلت ما لا يقل عن
اربعه فلسطينيين خلال المداهمه
على الغبره يسري شبابنا ولدت على العين كل
سنه يروح من المشاهدين
هيطلع مليون زبيده حتى ني الحريه لو
استقلالنا اقامت دولتنا الفلسطينيه على
كامل تراب من الفلسطينيين باذن الله
تعلن حركه الجهاد الاسلامي ان القتيلين من
قادتها وان احدهما كان قائدا لكتيبه جنين
التي تشهد الى جانب مدينه نابلس المجاوره
عمليات عسكريه مكثفه منذ سلسله الهجمات
التي نفذها الفلسطينيون في شوارع مدن
اسرائيليه في شهر مارس اذار الماضي تقول
اسرائيل ان قواتها تعرضت خلال مداهمه جنين
لاطلاق نار بعدما دخلت هناك بهدف القاء
القبض على عدد من المسلحين المطلوبين
لديها
يفاقم العنف في الضفه الغربيه حاله الجمود
الدبلوماسي منذ توقف في محادثات السلامه
التي كانت ترعاها الولايات المتحده بين
السلطه الفلسطينيه واسرائيل عام 2014 ومن
المرجح ان تضم الحكومه الاسرائيليه
المقبله برئاسه من يمينه الياهو سياسيين
من اليمين المتطرف الذين يعرضون قيام دوله
فلسطينيه ويدعون لتفكيك السلطه